الله
[Silence]
سبحانه وتالى
‏bec ir bec unable
not
because of something sin that they comm
of and
even though they arey their
الله
[Silence]
‏ironable
thisp
constantly and foring and constant
anxiety and constant parano
and af because theyve done this that is
not ever for them and so forth and their
life starts to implod this is not الله
سبحانه وتالى
الله
make
سبحانه وتعالى نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يغفر لنا خطايانا
نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يجعل في قلوبنا ا
خوفه وان يجعل في قلوبنا خشيته سبحانه حق
الخشيه وان يفقهنا في ديننا وانا يجعل
الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا مبلغ علمنا والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا
هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله.
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون.
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من
نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله اتقوا
الله وقولوا قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
فيقول الله تعالى في كتابه الكريم
المتابلوه
عليكم محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم هو غايه
الكتاب
وهو غايه ما انزل الله عز وجل على عباده
وحيا
وهو غايه الهدى
فيقول تعالى ذلك الكتاب لا ريب فيه هدى
للمتقين
‏that many of us are with we have it
have
taken time
and
tells first
‏B
the paragon
of the B which has to all of the Quran
he says it is a guidance there is no in
it it is a guidance it is a guide for
those who
متقين
المتقون
المتقين
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
تقوى
ما هي التقوى التي ذكرها الله وامر بها
الله سبحانه سبحانه وتعالى
العلماء يعرفون التقوى في كتاب الله
بان التقوى
هي اتخاذ وقايه
من عذاب الله بفعل اوامره واجتناب نواهيه
التقوى
personield
الله
الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ادعيها
wouldم
اني اعوذ برضاك من سخطك
وبمعافاتك من عقوبتك
واعوذ بك منك
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
صلى الله عليه وسلم دعاء والله
inek
andivment
from
اللهعا
الله
ابن عباس
الله ففروا الى الله يقول ابن عباس ففروا
الى الله اي فروا من الله الى الله
سبحانه وتالى
‏not
only
ours for why do we do them why do we do
these good deeds in order to incur
Allah's pleasure
we do these good deeds in order to make
ourselves fit
صلى الله عليه وسلم
قاربوا وسددوا
واعملوا وابشروا واعلموا انه لن يدخل
احدكم الجنه عمله
قالوا ولا انت يا رسول الله قال ولا انا
الا ان يتغمدني الله برحمه منه وفضله الله
اكبر لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
صلى الله عليه
الله
[Silence]
قل بفضل الله وبرحمته
فبذلك فليفرحوا
هو خير مما يجمعون
الله
[Silence]
that
contains and all person couldire in
the propet
‏ups other
accurate and asent
those as you can and rejoice but keep in
mind
that no matter how many good deeds you
do you will not enter parad based solely
on your deeds your deeds alone will not
admit you into parad
they saider
‏I will only parad after
me in paron and in gra
so what is this this is that we reach
out to
waala we make an intention a decision in
our heart
‏makeit paron make meit
for your forgiveness
make me theay in your that you shape to
what you choos
this is what a person is doing a person
is reaching out to
we do our
‏willad
asnay
not
will parad
because
would faather
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏gra
all mery
all
of mercy you have seen
any gooding you had any mercy that you
see from a parent
‏any people any
الله سبحانه وى
الله
سلمان الفارسي
صحيح مسلم صلى الله عليه وسلم
جعل الله الرحمه
100 جزء جعل الله الرحمه يعني الرحمه التي
اقتسمها لعباده
يرحم بها عباده جعلها 100 جزء
فانزل منها جزءا واحدا
الى الارض
فبها يتراحمون
وبها يتعاطفون اي الخلق كلهم
بهذه الرحمه الواحده يتعاطفون ويتراحمون
حتى يرفع ال الوحش حافره عن ولده
واخر الله 99
جزءا يرحم بها عباده يوم القيامه
‏mery
to
he has made it into parts
and one
of those 100 parts he has sent down to
be shared among the creation in this
earth he said from so from that one part
of Allah's mercy
‏even a parent to child every mercy that
was and is to be on this earth until the
day of judg is part of that one part and
he hased
99 parts that he ‏will exercise and show
to his creation on the day of judg if
all of this is one part of mercy can you
it is unimaginable the amount of mercy
that Allah will show to us on the day of
judg may Allah make us of those who
areown that mercy
our chances of going to parad skyrocket
we
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏you
said not me
will paradeloped
me in mery and gra only
the prop محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏sit
our
mery
soes
the worship of the obedience of Allah
we are seeking protction from الله in
the question
‏and tells thisران
is a guance for the people of
but here the
right here the part of it which is
at first glance unclear
‏Where do we learn from? From the Quran
how do we become متقin from the Quran?
But Allah tells us that the Quran is a
guidance for the
as if we are to be
receive the Quran in to be included in
the guidance of the Quran.
متقين guر
byرينقينر
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
‏icely
upon
you notic that the
more
and
of getting
‏us more and they us get more bad
because all of us is on a trajectory
our
is to find ourselves on that to
our is to make theion to
into the cycle of
‏areقين
areر
more areر
more areقين
more areق more are gu
and goes
الله سبحانه وتالى
take
first
you willyle
makeally
and go
the props
لعن الله السارق يسرق البيضه فتقطع يده
ويسرق الحبل فتقطع يده اجمع العلماء على
انه لا قطع دون ربع دينار فلا يمكن لاحد
ان يسرق بيضه فتقطع يده فماذا يعني النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم بهذا
لان البيضه لا تعدل ربع دينار حتى يكون ثم
قطع في حد الله ولكن المقصود ان اول سرقه
سرقها
فادمن على السرقه فسرق وسرق وسرق حتى قطعت
يده متى قطعت يده؟ عندما سرق البيضه
الاولى
عندما سرق الحبل الاول قطعت يده
صلى الله عليه وسلم
لعن الله
[Silence]
‏hand is not cut steing
there value
that a person has to reach that
threshold of value for their hand to be
cut off
so what does this narration mean it
means that a person when they start to
steal the first time they steal
‏What is that first?
Usually is something
eg something
very worthless but their confidence
grows then their greed grows
their eyes get longer and longer and
they
‏ste things are more valuable and more
valuable and one day that tr is the
station and they get cau and when they
get cau their hand get cut off but when
did their hand get cut off the first
time they stepped onto that tr that's
really when their hand got cut off that
first eg that they stle that's when
their hand really got cut off
and ‏So the point is is that we are to
reach out to Allah and he delivers us.
‏This is how worship الله and this is
why tells us
you alone do we worship and you alone
aid
in to worship Allah we must be aided by
Allah and in to be aided by
alone
and person makes that chice
الله
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يغفر لنا خطايانا وان يتوب علينا وان
يرحمنا اجمعين والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
[Arabic recitation]
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما بعد
فقد اخرج الامام البخاري في صحيحه باسناده
عن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه ان رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
الله عز وجل من عاد لي وليا فقد اذنته
بالحرب
يقول من عاد لي وليا فقد اذنته بالحرب
يعني اعلنت عليه الحرب وما تقرب الي عبدي
بشيء احب الي مما افترضته علي ولا يزال
عبدي يتقرب الي بالنوافل حتى احبه
فاذا احببته
كنت سمعه الذي يسمع به وبصره الذي يبصر به
يده التي يبطش بها ورجله التي يمشي بها
وان سالني لاعطينه
وان استعاذني لاعيذنه
وفي روايه زاد
اذا تقرب الي عبدي شبرا تقربت اليه ذراعا
واذا تقرب الي شبرا تقربت اليه ذراعا واذا
تقرب الي ذراعا تقربت اليه
باعا
وان اتاني يمشي اتيته هرولا
صلى الله عليه وسلم صحيح البخاري
الله
‏to
him
and ifes out
I willength
and coming
willlyق
[Silence]
‏another
‏He said, "And my servant then continues
to gain nearness to me with optional
forms of worship until I come to love
him.
‏And if I grow to love, if I come to
love my servant, I will be his ey with
which he sees and I will act as his ears
with which he
I will act as his hand with which he
grabs. And I will act as feet upon which
he walks.
‏And if he comes, he says, and if he ask
me, I will give him and if he seek
refuge in me, I will grant him refuge
and I will protect him.
وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا يوم الميعاد.
اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اتنا ربنا في
الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار اللهم استعملنا قبل موتنا اللهم
استعملنا في الاعمال الصالحه قبل موتنا
اللهم استعملنا اللهم لا تستبدلنا اللهم
ارفع من شاننا اللهم ربنا
اتمم لنا نورنا واغفر لنا واعف عنا يا
ربنا اللهم لا تدع لنا في هذا الجمع ذنبا
الا غفرته ولا دينا الا قضيته ولا هما الا
فرجته ولا عسيرا الا يسرته اللهم ربنا
ظلمنا انفسنا وان لم تغفر لنا وترحمنا
لنكون من الخاسرين اللهم ربنا انصر
الاسلام والمسلمين واخذل الشرك والمشركين
وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم فقهنا في ديننا الذي هو عصمه امرنا
ولا تجعل الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا مبلغ علمنا
اللهم اغسل حوبتنا اللهم اسلل سخيمه
قلوبنا اللهم طهر لنا قلوبنا اللهم اهدنا
واهد بنا اللهم زكي نفوسنا اللهم ات
نفوسنا تقواها وزكها انت خير من زكاها انت
وليها ومولاها والله اعلم صلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد كانت الصلاه
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا اللهشغل
المروحه ولا عليه استووادوا
‏shoulder to take a
feet are as in with the shoulders and
feet of your two nebors on side of you
as possible we will largely be judged
and reward for our prayer today based on
the straightness and coherence of our
rose please double check your make they
are silent
[Arabic recitation]
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
القارع
ما القارع
وما
ادراكما القارعا
يوم يكون الناس كالفراش
المبثوث
وتكون الجبال كالعهن المنفوش
فاما من ثقلت موازينه
فهو في عيشه راضيه
واما من خفت موازينه
فامه
هاويه
وما
ادراكما هي نار حاميه
الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
الهاكم التكاثر
حتى زرتم المقابر
كلا سوف تعلمون
ثم كلا سوف تعلمون
كلا لو تعلمون علم اليقين
لترون
الجحيم
ثم لترونها
عين اليقين
ثم لتسالن
يومئذ عن نعيم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر اللهم
انت السلام ومنك السلام
‏you have you want to hear announ so at
least you have children pleas listen to
my announ caref we have a very exciting
pram
will be the leading the summer pr for
this year so this is going to be our
opportunity to see if we can strengthen
our prs in more one
‏let me happ and youally ask question
and make
minম would you
en
first the pr be up to the of 17 18 want
to make all the classes are going to be
speciফ and be
‏areing
duration of norally
prmer this time
and other of will be will be a signicant
exciting
addition archery h back riding the
kids will be getting a ch
‏not onlyle
they will be also going outside for the
trips and making sure the things are
done some of them may come into the
gymnasum or some of them the kids may
have to go to the other location mention
few of those archy h back ring water g
bing trip so s and cfts and science
exper so there are many many things that
‏mind
pleas
and take care
any question pleas
বদ ইমাম আরাইল
গাইড
is
মল schrম
type affiliation
পফডমি
পিফ
‏have desire to something at coule
of stud are coming for show desire c of
fam but we need to have at least you
know or 10 fam parcipating in to make it
worthwi and the question of age groups
and all that stff so answer all those
questions once we have the people show
their interest pleas let us again
brother or ‏let us and sister
she is one of the key she is responsible
for the school pr so definல she would
to talk to you you have child of
that and your desire is to have teach
them the along with thedurumই
pleas donate generously on the way جزاكم
الله خيرا السلام عليكم السلام ورحمه الله
ايوهعليكم السلام
[Silence]
السلام
আস